in this lesson you're going to learn how
to find the endpoint when you're given a
midpoint and one of the other end points
so I'm going to show you two different
methods for doing this one a more formal
method and one kind of like a shortcut
method so let's take a look at this
first example so it says find the
endpoint a of segment a b given that the
midpoint m is negative 1 4 and the other
endpoint B is at 2 9. now let's graph it
you don't have to graph this each time
that you do these problems but just to
kind of help us to visualize so here's a
b at 2 9 here's our midpoint at negative
1 4.
and if we were to draw this segment it
basically looks something like like this
right so you've got a midpoint
you've got your endpoint which is 2 9
midpoint negative 1 4 and then you have
this other point here which we don't
know this is point a which is what we're
trying to solve for let's just call it X
comma y okay because we don't know the x
coordinate and the y coordinate now when
you find the midpoint it's like finding
an average like you add the x
coordinates and divide by two that's how
you find the middle and then you add the
Y coordinates and divide by two so just
like an average so what we're going to
do is we're going to say X plus 2
divided by 2 equals the x coordinate of
the midpoint and we're going to do the
same thing for the Y's y plus nine
divided by 2 equals the y coordinate of
the midpoint okay now we're going to
solve these two equations we're going to
multiply both sides by 2 instead of
dividing by 2 and do the opposite
multiply both sides by 2. so now we have
X plus 2 equals negative two and if we
subtract 2 from both sides you can see
that x equals negative four over here if
we multiply both sides by 2 we get y
plus nine equals eight and if we
subtract nine from both sides we get y
equals negative one so the coordinates
of our our Point here a is going to be
at negative 4 negative one and if we
plot that you can see this is Left 4
down 1 right here and you can see that
the midpoint is halfway between uh
point a and point B now I was telling
you there's a shortcut method for doing
this and let me see if I can show you
this so what you would do is you'd say
hmm how am I getting from 2 to negative
1. well you can see I'm subtracting 3.
so if I do that same thing if I subtract
3 again
negative 1 minus
3 gives us negative 4 right let's do the
same thing for the Y so how am I getting
from 9 to 4 I'm subtracting 5. so if I
subtract 5 again what's 4 minus 5
negative 1. now your this is good for
taking like a standardized test but
usually when you're doing it like on a
test in your class your teacher is going
to want to see the use of the midpoint
formula here so let's take a look at
another example see if you can do this
one on your own
okay for number two we have find
endpoint J of segment J K given that the
midpoint m is at negative 2 1 and the
other endpoint K is at the point 2
negative 2. how would you do that one
see if you can pause the video try this
one on your own the way I like to do it
is just draw a segment and it doesn't
have to be like a perfect graph like in
a x y coordinate plane you can just draw
something just kind of back of the
envelope style here where we have
endpoint J and point K and the midpoint
here in the middle that's negative 2 1 J
we don't know so let's call that X comma
Y and K we do know which is at 2 comma
negative 2. so let's do the formal
method first so what I would do is I
would average the two endpoints to get
the midpoint so I'm going to say X plus
2 so add the two x coordinates together
and divide by 2 and that equals the x
coordinate of the midpoint and let's do
the same thing for the Y so we're going
to say y plus negative 2. divided by 2
equals the y coordinate of the midpoint
okay now all we have to do is solve so
instead of dividing by 2 I'm going to
multiply both sides by 2. that way these
cancel we've got X plus 2 equals
negative 4. If I subtract 2 from both
sides we get x equals negative 6. and
over here if I multiply both sides by 2
the 2's cancel we get y plus negative 2
equals two and if I add 2 to both sides
you can see that Y is coming out to 4
and so that's the end point over here
it's going to be at the point so J is at
negative 6
comma 4. Now another way to check your
work is
to go ahead and look at negative 6 4 you
could say negative 6 plus 2 is negative
4 divided by 2 is negative 2. that
checks out 4 plus negative 2 is 2
divided by 2 is equal to one that checks
out or if you want to do that shortcut
method right say okay how am I going
from this x coordinate to this x
coordinate I'm subtracting 4 so 2 minus
4 is negative 2 and then negative 2
minus 4 again gives us negative 6. same
thing here negative two plus three is
one one plus three is four and that's a
quick shortcut way to check your work so
great job if you're able to follow the
concepts here in this video if you want
more practice and you want to see some
more examples follow me over to that
previous video that I did talking about
midpoints and finding endpoints and I'll
see over in that video I'll see you
there